[Music]
good morning John it is Wednesday
December 19th and because it is a
Wednesday you know and everybody should
know that of course I have to sing a
song and this is the final song
wednesday of brotherhood 2.0 because it
is my last wednesday holy crap
but it is also a historic song wednesday
because it is the first song wednesday
in which i am not going to be alone in
my singing because catherine is going to
help me
she wrote probably about a half of this
song actually she was very excited about
the whole secret project she was in
there commenting with everyone else we
had a Mission Control in our basement
and and we had a lot of fun this song is
about the secret project for awesome
[Music]
December 17th was the day the project
for awesome got underway with a goal to
decrease worldsuck with the help of sexy
bill Nelson what that bucket was the day
that the next to go for you two
they got together too
that believe it or not their Center
screenshot was actually more powerful
into
you
people from motive 300 charities like
levees dawn work Toys for Tots and
Autism Speaks they're fighters of every
race creed and age thick commenting that
to the most discussed page II was
the day that the nerve to cover you do
they got together to prove that
believe it or not their Center
screenshot was actually more powerful
into boobs was the day that the Nerds
took over you
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was our song the secret project
was really exciting and not only was it
sort of fantastically jokes I guess it
made me kind of hopeful seeing all these
people that I know and people that I
don't know promoting these organizations
that are doing really good things and
there are so many of them so many people
doing awesome stuff in the world just
because they think that it's the right
thing to do
thanks for everyone who participated
think you think you think you think I do
that more should I say thank you more
and thanks to everyone who skipped
school or didn't go into work I didn't
go into work that day either I'm not
looking forward to your punishment
proposals me either because I'm the one
that has to video yet it that's true
generally does have to be holding the
camera the person who said that I had to
pay five dollars for every hand gesture
in every video that is a really bad idea
I probably would would would be
destitute there's no other way for me to
show how excited I am
we show John I'm not looking forward to
your punishment proposals but I will see
them and you tomorrow
there anything you want to say to John
what is our Christmas present John has
called us like five minutes ago he was
like what kind of manga do you like it I
love you buck I'm gonna turn it off I
don't know how much of this I'm gonna be
able to use right